herzinfarkte mit hilfe künstlicher
nano-partikel vorhersagen depression mit
software behandeln und hautkrebs durch
algorithmen diagnostizieren das alles
ist nicht das drehbuch für einen neuen
science-fiction-film sondern die ziele
von großen tech firmen wie microsoft
facebook amazon apple und google
denn die sind fest davon überzeugt das
verständnis von krankheiten sei
letztendlich ein daten problem das
gelöst werden muss wie das genau
funktionieren soll und ob das nicht nur
die medizin sondern tatsächlich unsere
komplette welt schon bald auf den kopf
stellt jetzt in science fiction herzlich
willkommen
die forschungs hauptquartier von
microsoft geht es schon länger nicht
mehr um windows oder wird es geht um
behandlung und heilung von
tumorpatienten
doch es wird nicht direkt an patienten
und patientinnen geforscht sondern
beispielsweise einen dreidimensionalen
computertomografie darstellung das ziel
den krebs besiegen oder ihn zumindest
eindämmen und vernünftig behandeln zu
können sehr viel personal spezialisiert
auf medizinische informatik aber vor
allem unzählige server arbeiten an
diesem ziel
die beteiligten sind sie sicher da
findet gerade eine riesige revolution im
medizinbereich stadt und die treibenden
kräfte dabei sind der technische
fortschritt und die digitalisierung tech
giganten wie amazon apple google oder
facebook investieren in neues personal
aus den bereichen biologie medizin und
chemie und öffnen komplett neue
abteilungen zusammen mit software
experten und expertinnen sollen sie die
große rechenaufgabe lösen die
rechenaufgabe deren ergebnis am ende die
biologie entschlüsselt und uns
krankheiten von grund auf verstehen
lässt die medizinische datenverarbeitung
dient als grundpfeiler dieser logik die
instrumente künstliche intelligenz und
die analyse und auswertung riesiger
datenmengen innerhalb kürzester zeit das
ergebnis zellfunktionen verstehen genome
also die dna kostengünstig sequenzieren
und neue medikamente entwickeln in der
medizinischen grundlagenforschung im
bereich geht es aber auch um
grundsätzliche fragen wie wie können
patienten informationen wie puls insulin
oder blutwerte kontinuierlich analysiert
werden und wie können solche risiken
mengen an patienteninformationen
maschinell ausgewertet werden hier ein
paar konkrete beispiele aus der praxis
bei amazon geht es hauptsächlich um
virtuelle arztbesuche und darum wie sich
riesige datenmengen im medizinischen
bereich in einer cloud speichern lassen
mark zuckerberg der facebook gründer
unterstützt ein forschungszentrum das
einen menschlichen zelle atlas aufbauen
soll
google möchte mit hilfe von software
depressionen heilen und herzinfarkte mit
hilfe künstlicher nano-partikel
voraussagen
wow das klingt wirklich irre und das
alles läuft tatsächlich wie geschmiert
denn die rahmenbedingungen in den usa
sind optimal
das amerikanische gesundheitssystem
boomt mehr als 20 prozent der
staatsausgaben fließen in diese branche
zudem ist es für die tech firmen nicht
schwer ihre innovationen unter die leute
zu bringen die fdp also die
amerikanische
arzneimittelzulassungsbehörde hat erst
vor kurzem das prozedere beschleunigt
durch das technik medizin produkte
überhaupt für den markt zugelassen
werden dass alles basiert auf den
fortschritten im bereich der künstlichen
intelligenz und die sind nach meinung
vieler experten und experten innerhalb
kürzester zeit regelrecht explodiert
mittlerweile ist es gar nicht mehr nötig
software zu entwickeln stattdessen
entwickeln sie sich selbst da sie aus
daten lernt und genau das wollen sich
die forschungsabteilung zunutze machen
sowie microsoft in seinem projekt
hannover ihre idee computer könnten für
jeden einzelnen patienten jede einzelne
patienten individuell angepasst den
medikamenten cocktails finden statt
einen wirkstoff nach dem anderen zu
testen könnte intelligente software auf
grundlage der genomischen daten der
patienten die literatur nach der
perfekten medikamentenkombination
durchsuchen auf einen schlag können so
tausende von kombinationen analysiert
werden und dem ärzte-team vorgeschlagen
werden
durch die zusammenarbeit mit dem
menschen könnten die maschinen dann
sogar immer weiter dazulernen und ihre
intelligenz ausbauen so etwas ähnliches
derzeit wird das bereits in einem
pilotprojekt in eugen getestet und zwar
am night cancer institute for microsoft
künstliche intelligenz also
entscheidungshilfe als eine art
arzthelfer mit schier unendlichem wissen
und das ist nicht das einzige projekt
das hoffnung macht ibm
eine ki entwickelt die die dna
sequenzierung eines gehirntumors
schneller und zuverlässiger analysiert
hat als das gesamte team von experten in
israel arbeitet ein forschungsteam an
einem virtuellen gesundheits assistenten
der die patienten und patientinnen im
chat berät die maschine hat zugriff auf
eine riesige datenbank und alle aufnahme
protokolle bei wunsch zudem auf die
persönlichen daten der patienten auch
wenn es immer wieder kritik an dieser
datensammelei gibt in diesen fällen ist
das nicht nur äußerst sinnvoll sondern
bildet tatsächlich die basis für diese
art von forschung die gefahr allerdings
bleibt was passiert wenn konten gehackt
und fremde vollen zugriff auf die
gesamten persönlichen wirklich intimen
daten von patientinnen bekommen
abgesehen von einem hacker-angriff wer
genau hat zugriff auf die daten
krankenkassen etwa die so viel mehr über
ihre mitglieder erfahren als diesen
vielleicht lieb es doch genau das ist
der spagat nur wenn die maschinen vollen
zugriff auf möglichst viele daten haben
können sie funktionieren die frage also
lohnte sich dafür alle seine daten
herzugeben
eine große vision der tech firmen ist es
übrigens auch die menschlichen biologie
irgendwann einmal so steuern zu können
wie eine software dna könnte dann
beispielsweise programmiert werden
ebenso wie zellen
dies ist einem forschungsteam der
stanford university tatsächlich schon
gelungen und soll nun weiter
perfektioniert werden dazu muss man
verstehen wie sie funktionieren denn so
die idee ließe sich eine
programmiersprache erfinden um ihre
steuerung zu übernehmen krebs in einer
zelle ließ sie sich so also erkennen und
der molekulare computer könnte in diesem
fall das kommando selbstmord befehl
natürlich nur für die krebszellen wenn
ihr kein video zum thema und auch zu
allen anderen themen verpassen wollt
dann wird mir her ein abo aufs auge und
vergesst nicht den genau auf die glocke
nur dann verpasst er kein video hier
geht es weiter mit dafür draufklicken
bedroht künstliche intelligenz die
menschheit mit den gefahren die von ki
ausgehen ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran